[موسيقى]
الصيام المتقطع هو نوع من
المصطلح الضخم هذه الأيام ، فهو
يعني في الأساس أنه ستكون هناك أوقات من
اليوم أو الأسبوع لا تأكل فيها
على الإطلاق ، وأعتقد أن هناك دليلًا جيدًا على
أن هذا يمكن أن يعزز فقدان الوزن
وربما حتى  الصحة العامة من
الواضح أن هذا ليس شيئًا لكل شخص
أعتقد أنك تعرفه عندما يتعلق الأمر
بتغييرات كبيرة في نظامك الغذائي بغض النظر عما
يجب أن تتحدث إليه مع شخص يعرف
ما إذا كان خبير تغذية أو ربما حتى
طبيبك أحد الأشياء التي
تسمعها  الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
يصومون بشكل متقطع هو أنهم إذا كانوا
يأكلون الأنواع الصحيحة من الأطعمة ، فإنهم في
الواقع ليسوا كلهم يعانون من ال
يام المتقطع والجائع ويتطلبون الكثير من
لإرادة إذا كنت لا تشعر أن لد
ك قوة الإرادة وأنك تعرف نف
ك  من الأفضل على الأرجح أن
تكتشف حقًا ما هي السعرات الحرارية التي
تتناولها في اليوم ، وكيف تتأكد من أنها
سعرات حرارية ذات نوعية جيدة وتلتزم
بهذا النظام الغذائي المعقول الذي سيساعدك على
العيش حتى 100 سعر حراري.